nancy c'est ronnie passe des heures
chaque semaine à la rencontre des
chevaux sauvages les fameux me stein de
l'ouest américain
cela fait 17 ans qu ils les observent
dans les montagnes du wyoming tout près
de la frontière avec le montana
et l'on a recensé elle-même 185 dans ce
parc naturel et les connaît tous par
leur nom
ce matin ils sont quelques-uns à se
nourrir de sauge sur le bord de la route
ils nous ignorent presque en traversant
pour aller boire l'eau du lac
inya ce spectacle si apaisant et si
magique ferait presque oublier que ces
chevaux sont trop nombreux dans dix
états de l'ouest plus de 90000
ce qui cause des problèmes pour la faune
et la flore environnante
alors périodiquement les autorités
fédérales en capture pour mettre moins
de pression sur les écosystèmes et en
prennent soin mais il y en a beaucoup
la solution les offrir en adoption
adoptez un must find c'est ce qu'a fait
émis au montana passionné de chevaux et
l'a accueilli
ne lui a pas coûté très cher
25 dollars pour ce meeting mais elle a
dû prévoir quelques milliers de dollars
pour l'entraîner et bien sûr l'enclos
nécessaire et il y a une autre chose à
considérer
depuis cinquante ans plus de 240 mille
chevaux sauvages ont été adoptés ou
vendus à des éleveurs mais la demande
est bien plus faible que l'offre et la
sécheresse qui causent la famine
n'arrange rien
sept mille autres bêtes qui vont grossir
davantage les rangs du cheptel adopter
pour nancy c'est ronnie le contrôle de
cette surpopulation de façon humaine est
essentiel at inc
[Musique]
l'adoption reste donc la priorité pour
les autorités fédérales a fait que ce
symbole de l'ouest américain continue
d'évoluer dans ces plaines et ses
montagnes
mais pis pour fillon perdent des chevaux
si adoré par nancy qui continue en
attendant de les aimer tous autant
qu'ils sont